as the gunman fired more than 70 shots
from a high-powered rifle the crowd
panicked
in the chaos of the Highland Park
Massacre police say Robert Crema blended
into the crowd dressed as a woman and
fled Primo was dressed in women's
clothing and investigators do believe he
did this to conceal his facial tattoos
and his identity and help him during the
escape with the other people who were
fleeing those who survived the
Independence Day shooting are
traumatized mentally exhausted mentally
shooken anxious scared female fearful
and enraged this would be running
through our heads for
forever leaving one AR-15 style assault
rifle on the rooftop perch police say he
tossed another one in his mother's car
and drove to Madison Wisconsin then back
to Illinois where an alert driver
reported the car and police took him
down with little effort
the toll from the massacre reached seven
on Tuesday after an injured victim died
38 more are wounded on Tuesday
prosecutors named Crema as the Highland
Park killer today the Lake County
State's Attorney's office has charged
Robert crimo III with seven counts of
first-degree murder
for The Killing Spree that he has
Unleashed against our community
these are just the first of many charges
that will be filed against Mr cremo I
want to emphasize that there will be
more charges
Crema led a troubled life before the
attack
in April 2019 a relative called police
and said Crema had tried to commit
suicide a week earlier in September of
that year a relative called police and
said he had threatened to kill the
entire family and had a collection of
knives and swords police confiscated
them then authorities say the
21-year-old amassed an Arsenal including
the assault rifle he used in the attack
it was bought legally they say he had a
second assault rifle pistols possibly a
shotgun and then he spent weeks planning
a massacre vice president Kamala Harris
came to Highland Park and called for a
Crackdown on the epidemic of American
gun violence there is no
no Rin that we have weapons of war on
the streets of America we need
reasonable gun safety laws
police identified six people who died
immediately Catherine Goldstein 88
Jacqueline Sondheim 63 Stephen Strauss
88 and Nicholas Toledo Zaragoza 78.
there were also two parents who left
behind a two-year-old child Arena
McCarthy 35 and her husband Kevin
McCarthy 37 John hendron Al Jazeera
Highland Park Illinois